non mais en fait y'a une différence
c'est que here les candidats qui ont été
battus eux c'est tout sauf le pen et ils
veulent comme valérie pécresse qui a un
qui rêve d'être miss de mâcon donc c'est
tout sauf le pen et les français dans la
rue c'est tout sauf macron non moi je
préfère être du côté des français dans
la rue non y'a des français dans leur
rugby il ya eu prévu il ya même une
arène ya des gens qui disent
qu'on subit pas les voilà ce que les
urnes manuel macron et et moi en fait au
second tour on nous dit mais où sont vos
réserves de voix mais en fait nous
réserve de voix chez ccg tous ceux qui
ont voté contre et magnanac ans et les
70% de français ont voté contre emmanuel
mac alors c'est les jeunes c'est les
jeunes qui ont subi la baisse des apl
c'est les jeunes qui sont exposés à
l'insécurité que si le bilan de la
police juste juste de demain contre la
clé de voûte de cette élection on le
sait c'est jean luc mélenchon à 22 21%
et jean luc mélenchon hier n'a pas
appelé bo a voté pour emmanuel et mâcon
mais il a appelé à voter contre marine
le pen donc mais il a quand même un
réservoir de voix incroyable talent cc
c'est jean luc mélenchon qui va faire le
président non jorda 6022 non parce que
je pense que les candidats sont soit pas
trop pressée grace et valérie pécresse
et je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
d'électeurs de jean luc mélenchon qui ne
voteront pas et manuellement mais ce
sont les électeurs de jean luc mélenchon
qui vont faire bouger les résidents oui
et puis tous les abstentionnistes parce
que la participation va probablement
augmenter mais c'est vrai qu'une partie
du vote des électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon va avoir une influence sur le
sur le côté mais moi je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup d'électeurs de jean luc
mélenchon qui voteront pour nous parce
que beaucoup veulent pas la retraite à
65 ans ils ont été horrifié de voir
qu'on a suspendu 15000 soignants sans
salaire qu'on a imposé le pass sanitaire
que mes langues mais que ma croix
totalement balayé les gilet jaune le
référendum 17e' citoyenne que nous on a
dans le projet et a énormément et pour
qu'ils voient que jean luc mélenchon
juste
jordan bardella aujourd'hui on voit tout
sauf le pen parce que c'est vrai que
marine le pen on voit d'un oeil et des
gens ont peur de voir marine le pen au
pouvoir que vous pourriez leur dire
c'est moi laurent ça il y en a qui
disent que le plein d'appels lire je dis
voilà enfin d'apple lire cyril toi
maintenant kita raconte en politique je
passe quelques mois si marine le pen
était présidente c'est la question tout
oppose ils se passeraient quoi oui oui
je suis jean s'est bâti
d'abord les taxes sur l'énergie vont
baisser ça c'est une des premières
mesures qu'on va prendre sur le
carburant sur l'électricité le gaz le
fioul ou les taxes il ya plein de gens
qui m'appellent et qui me disent
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si marine le
pen serait et était présidente exactions
qui auraient beaucoup qui flippe vous
avez leur dire je veux leur dire que
emmanuel macron pendant cinq ans un vrai
que j'aurais toujours mokhtar mais
divisés
nos plages ne ramènent toujours avec moi
ça qui devait pas être là c'est pas
motard je les ramène partout donc c'est
moi je fais pas la 3d non enfin c'est
pas non mais sam volontiers avec quand
même une on a marqué quand même beaucoup
de différence avec ce qui a pu être dit
pendant la campagne moi je veux dire mes
parents ils sont pas nés ici mais pareil
sont pas nés ici ils sont arrivés
d'italie dans les années 60 ils ont fait
un effort de travail et de s'intégrer
d'aimer la france il ya beaucoup de
générations qui ont fait cet effort là
j'ai un appartement vous êtes français
vous êtes considérés comme français et
sans aucune autre distinction est rien
dans le programme qu'on a les français
peuvent aller mais rien dans le projet
dans les propositions que fait marine le
pen amènerait une discrimination et vous
savez je vais vous dire marine le pen le
raconte souvent elle racontait chez vous
quand elle était quand elle était enfant
quand elle est quant à lui 5 6 7 ans 8
ans quand elle était à l'école la
discrimination tant que fille de le pen
elle a subi elle a subi parce que les
enseignants voulaient pas là disait aux
enfants te mets pas à côté parce que
c'est une fille le pen elle vous la
raconter tout cela et jamais ne lui
viendrait à l'idée de mettre en pratique
de re mettre en pratique une
discrimination donc j'ai un appartement
où vous êtes français vous avez une
carte d'identité française vous aimez la
france vous considérer comme français
mais vous êtes les bienvenus dans le
combat national qu'on me voit c'est tout
le reste sont des caricatures mais juste
moi je dis là dans les deux semaines qui
ont séparé aux gens qui vous appelle
lâche 1 à les lire le programme vous
fiez pas aux caricatures vous fiez pas
aux sirènes est allé lire le ressentir
il ya très peu de gens qui fait
franchement et resserrée qui a lu le
programme ici l'invité enfants derrière
un mec qui l'a lu non mais la voir c'est
bien
régnier c'est bien de savoir pourquoi on
vote non mais c'est vrai alors laurent
fontaine ouais tout sauf marine le pen
qu'on a besoin je voudrais dire deux
choses la première c'est que moi je suis
pas au niveau de jordan bardella suis
très honoré d'être face au patron du
rassemblement national ce soir je l'aï m
de télé je suis un citoyen engagé et on
sert j'ai bossé avec la reine ne le
cache pas et c est vrai que c est ces
courageux d'être là encore laurent parce
qu'après il s'en prend plein les yeux le
soleil tape la gueule mais c'est
vraiment aller avec jarden parlait à
tout à l'heure lll lan en ligne dès que
tu passes sur ce plateau pour défendre
le président macron elle est
inimaginable or je vais dire du sanwi
online pour personne ouais mais onze
joueurs ni pour emmanuel macron nippon
marine le pen
mélenchon le reçoit à chaque fois à la
hongrie les marrons et je voudrais dire
un truc même vous je suis sûr que vous
trouvez du talent jean luc mélenchon
comme moi je trouve que cela est de tous
les combats celui qui a fait l'une des
meilleures compagnies à marine le pen si
je fais une très bonne il n'y a pas de
haine je ris que nous sommes aussi voilà
avec lui voilà c'est ça malgré les
désaccords genre va de bardella parce
qu'il va aller chasser un peu sur les
terres des électeurs de mélenchon
n'enjolive calmons nous sans mélenchon
après les récentes ont fait ça brille
c'est un bon c'est intelligent donc je
suis fidèle jusqu il a entendu le chien
juste parce que j'ai aussi le plus vieux
de cette banque que vous êtes ce soir
peut-être moins des pulls public et que
moi j'ai gagné le monde
mais moi je m'intéresse à la politique
depuis très jeune j'ai été membre d'un
parti à saison donc je m'intéresse à la
politique j'ai la mémoire et malgré tout
l'extrême droite ça restera l'extrême
droite alors bien sûr elles sont pas
concernés mais bien sûr à coups de
petits chats et à coups de douceur et à
coups de mer de la nation elle a réussit
parfaitement son boulot bravo à marine
le pen en terme de com c'est juste
génial et c'est bien fait sauf que
l'extrême droite ça arrive c'est très
droite et que vous êtes le patron d'un
parti aujourd'hui qui est entré ce 12 a
été créé avec jean marie le pen et avec
deux anciens hauts elfes nss je sais pas
si les gens savent ce que c'est que des
mâles fénay cesse bousquet et léon
gautier mais non monsieur
vous étiez chez pascal praud ce midi il
vous a dit un truc très juste sur une
ville de la région parisienne vous
l'avez dit n'importe quoi tout le monde
a pu déboguer vous aviez tort il avait
raison sur quoi sur les subventions qui
ont été retirés un club de foot dans la
ville de mantes la ville mais par le
parlement par le maire de cette ville
qui était le seul maire rassemblement
national parce que les béninois être
d'arabes certainement aux clubs ou
british et n'importe quoi vous monte
alors comme ça on va prendre souvent
vers les amis je suis allé voir bah
c'est vrai vous ne connaissez pas le 2
je suis désolé rentrée
m qui peut se demander aussi attend à ce
que j'ai envie de savoir comment ça se
passe sur les mairies qui sont devenus
et rennes la quasi 99% nos maires ont
été élus dès le premier tour ce qui veut
dire que quand on fait le boulot et je
vais vous dire on arrive même dans le
seville là à convaincre des gens qui
m'arrêtent nous était dans l'opposition
et même des gens qui nous ont combattu
et qui s'aperçoivent que ça l'objectif
le matin il qu'on est des gens
parfaitement rationnel parfaitement
raisonnable qu'est ce que vous répondez
simplement notre pays qui dit que c'est
un parti d'extrême droite mais je me
sens pas d'extrême droit rim et je vous
dis pas que vous avez internationale
quand il ya un français sur deux qui au
second tour votent marine le pen dans
les intentions de vote ne faut pas dire
qu'un français sur trois ans des groupes
il ya encore quelques jours marine le
pen et eric zemmour est ce que vous nous
reprochez secrètement jeu
je commence que ça déjà ce qui se passe
c'est l'extrême je mets ces jours
précédents qu'est-ce qui se passerait si
marine le pen était président ça c'est
la vraie question nous mais c'est là
qu'est ce que vous lui posez à lui mais
concrètement vous nous ferons dix ans à
thème dont concret l'approché que
j'aurais origine étrangère qui nous
écoutent vous dise vous inquiétez pas on
ne sera pas au prénom vous fera pas la
chasse je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
ça la véritable problématique c'est
qu'elle n'aura pas les moyens de
gouverner vous pouvez avoir tous les
programmes du monde est votre programme
il est la personne le mettra en place
pourquoi parce que marine le pen est
résident sur quoi stream prix du lait
soit via ma phrase et je vous écouterai
sera une président de cohabitation elle
cohabitera peut-être avec les insoumis
avec les mélenchon avec les
mélenchonistes avec les maquereaux dit
j'en sais rien mais mais parce qu'elle
n'aura pas la majorité à elle seule
allée et pourquoi pas c'est vous qui
faites les élections parce que je
pouvais y a un truc laurent fontaine
sont ces matches pareils
d'emmanuel
on a une tournée je vous le jure que à
l'époque
on puisse dans les séries dans une
course avec dur mais non je suis passé
tout parce qu'on va décider où et on ne
partage pas les mêmes choses macron 2017
il est parti avec un nombre de députés
ps plr qui le soutenaient déjà et puis
c'est un candidat centriste donc par
définition vous savez comment ça va j'ai
débuté il ya deux tours est bas au
deuxième tour les gens votent plutôt
pour celui qui la rend moins énervé ceux
là donc on en a une on a une majorité à
l'assemblée cette fois-ci vous ne
l'aurez pas donc c'est marine le pen qui
ne répondent jamais cette question la
retraite à 60 ans ok vous la mettez
comment quand et président que sans
pouvoir quand t'as pas de député mais
qu'est-ce que mémé vous raconte excusez
moi
n'importe comment vous faites
précédemment cinq semaines après il ya
une élection législative comment vous
vous obtenez en france en appui de 67
millions d'habitants que vous faites
plus de 15 millions de voix faire que
vous accédez à la présence de la
république vous avez la majorité
derrière et pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de députés
notamment des républicains de la frange
la peut-être la plus national des
républicains qui travailleront avec nous
marine a annoncé que son ministre de la
justice serait jean paul garraud jean
paul garraud c'est le père du parquet
national anti terroriste il vient des
républicains il a été député dlr pendant
20 ans donc on a autour de nous ce
serait qu'illusion premier ministre mais
jean marc meilleur mais pas définir son
premier match à peu près tous venez et
vous le dire pour y être premier
ministre mais non mais je pense que le
projet
sérieures du rassemblement la salle est
juste on a d'une chose c'est que c'est
pas le rn 4 c'est important je vous dit
kaka qui dira que je pense qu'elle fera
le choix je suis pas à sa place et là on
est dans le temps on choisit le
président ont choisi le projet de
société qu'on veut rebondir à le projet
nice qui lui-même fera la proposition
car on dirait du pin danger dans
l'institution scolaire du mans juste
nommé juge en termine si le seul
argument non c'est pas une sanction dans
les deux ou trois ans on n'aura pas la
majorité derrière ben franchement c'est
extrêmement léger là mon seul argument
s'il y adhérer à convaincre une majorité
ces contraventions au premier argument
était l'extrême droite ça reste
l'extrême droite mais ça me ça veut dire
que c'est à dire que l'on craigne moi je
ne soutiens pas un candidat qui est allé
donc c'est avec des néo nazis en
autriche comme marine et noah contre
jeunes micmacs que je raconte n'importe
quoi oui oui a confié craindre en garde
et les allées sur internet et regarder
son émission c'est surtout les deux
celui qui dit n'importe quoi c'était en
2002 vous le savez très bien d'avoir été
la leur tout bien sûr mais enfin où
aller les néonazis autrichien où les
connaissait pas le
nom mais dont vous traitez et je faisais
pas traiter nazis je vous ai dit que ce
parti avait été créée par des néo par
des nazis des gens qui avaient été des
nazis qui ont combattu sur le front de
l'est avec les allemands sous le sourire
je pense que le tout sauf le pen
aujourd'hui c'est plus audible pour les
gens qui attendent l'entendre dire 32
points mais j'avais le souvenir
deuxièmement vous n'aurez pas l'occasion
de mettre en place d'autres programmes
parce que mathématiquement et vous le
savez très bien c'est votre plus grande
crainte vous n'aurez pas la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale signé pour les
élections avant donnez le nous allons
gagner
troisième point important pardon mais
marine le pen n'a pas la compétence et
c'est pas moi qui le dit elle n'a pas la
hauteur de vue pourquoi demande à
philippe haut ce qu'ils pensent de
marine le pen pourtant il a été son plus
proche collaborateur elle est nulle elle
est pas bonne elle a passé travail et
demander à ce que zemmour dit eric
zemmour a dit marine le pen elle est
insuffisant
des manuels
d'histoire
[Applaudissements]
disputant il peut dire que c'est là
c'est le compte de capital ils peuvent
dire que c'est mais il faut il faudrait
que tu arrêtes parce que je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec toi on est dans un
débat d'idées je suis né dans un débat
que j'arrête quoi mais là tu reviens 20
ans
non mais attends excuse moi je termine
en quoi elle cet égard quand tu as dit
qu'il n'y avait que des fachos qui était
derrière les milices était caricatural
avec ses gencives et un voeu
tchouga et les fachos ce que j'aimerais
c'est que la france avait validé c'est à
dire que tu as aujourd'hui une france
mais qui n'est même plus fracturées tu
as une france des primes et un deux
candidats temps inquiets macron que tout
le monde connaît et dont
vraisemblablement une majorité des
français ne veut plus et puis tu as une
candidate pas d'eux qu'une candidate
mais je riais marine le pen qui est
marine le pen et qui arrivent sur le
terrain et qui n'a jamais été aussi près
de franchir les portes de l'elysée il
faut expliquer pourquoi concrètes mais
là on n'est pas en train de sérieux
d'allumer savoir aujourd'hui pourquoi
marine le besoin de ça ils ont besoin de
comprendre qu'ils vont choisir alors ils
sont assez grands pour le faire moi je
suis pas je suis pas de ceux qui disent
qu'il faut donner son vote ont poussé
les gens à évoluer pour l'un ou pour
l'autre mais ce que tu dis je trouve que
c'est hors troisième rang puisque
20 cadavres il y en a qui va s'appeler
champagne au kremlin il s'appelle
manière poutine il a déjà lancé
[Applaudissements]
résidente de ce pays le 24 avril c'est
une claque énorme thon dont on parle de
l'ukraine et on se plaint et des
massacres mais vous rendez compte pour
poutine génial emmanuel macron celui qui
incarne celui qui est contre moi est-ce
que les maquillages l'annuaire poutine
toutes les semaines au téléphone à m
france
mais oui pardon et gym et le tout sauf
le pen en fait ça marche pas ça peut
peut-être que ça marche et avant
aujourd'hui ça marche et de troncs
aujourd'hui c'est 32 % des gens qui
votent à l'extrême droite ou à la droite
ce qu'on dit radical donc en fait au
lieu de mettre la poussière sous le
tapis en disant ouais c'est des racistes
ouais c'est des fachos oui c'est un
party extrême ça ça ne fonctionne plus
il faut prendre tout à mon avis à mon
humble avis il faut prendre mais c'est
parce que ça marche quand on le sait pas
le nom mais avec un serveur de
diaboliser les acteurs enfin je veux
dire il faut qu'on soit partition que
j'ai des amis des arts il faut dire ça
c'est faux ça tournait à zioui mais je
n'ai pas
jordan le monde vous êtes vous n'étiez à
l'instant on le temps très
entendu ici que je m'agite les traits
les élections passées si si c'est là la
vieille rengaine c'est ça que c'est pour
ça que je peux vous soyez
vous montez viennent en fait vous n'avez
pas d'arguments sur le fond parce que
les français ne
s'agrandisse qu'on va faire vous
nourrissez minutes et
c'est un peu ringard ça ils vont essayer
ses élèves s'étaient quasiment sans
bouger traité personne de l'asie je vais
répéter dix fois vous continuerez dire
que j'ai traité quelqu'un de nazi et
genre des commentaires c'est
insupportable
ce niveau de démocratie qui n'existe
plus on peut écouter toi même tu dit à
traiter les gens que d'autres gagnés au
très chaud c'est faux nicolas c'est faux
relis ce que j'ai fait travailler un peu
alors gilbert n'est pas ce que j'ai dit
gilbert est en vous écoutant
respectueusement j'ai l'impression
d'écouter quelqu'un il ya 25 ans il ya
trente ans quoi pour moi vous êtes
complètement déphasé vous tenter de
diaboliser marine le pen c'est pas le
sujet vous n'êtes ni dans l'argumentaire
vous ne répondez pas sur le jdd parfois
qu'on est libre à haut niveau en quoi le
médium et mais elle n'est pas au niveau
elle est au 2e tour à la une chance de
gagner
des êtres humains qu'ils savaient pas
reconnaître un pays d'europe sur une
carte mais si c'est ça les arguments que
vous visitez cergy monsieur macro auprès
du manager des ventes chez bmw on pense
vous n'avez pas d'argent
mais de retrouver sur un ton très
franchement il vous a mis ko
c'est vrai et je suis j'espère que le 25
avril tuera pas pleurer voilà alors
aussi nicky juste votre analyse de ce
qui s'est passé
en une minute
ce que j'ai trouvé mois intéressant hier
celle les analyses sociologiques des
gens qui ont voté pour marine le pen
pour emmanuel mannoury arguments qu'ils
ont mélangé
mais c'est gênant parce que moi je ne
voterai jamais pour marine le pen mais
je dois dire que en l'entendant laurent
il a rendu un très bon service puisque
comme le camp de hillary clinton ou de
bord obama qui tapait sur trump en
permanence de la même façon avec les
mêmes arguments ils ont renforcé le
phénomène propre micro n'est pas comme
ça que l'on arrivera si on le souhaite à
combattre maeva l'antenne qui renforcera
quoi que ce soit vous ne donnez pas
autant d'importance que ça irait bien
reprocher quand je parle de compétences
ou mon avion 2010 est soi même ses
soutiens étaient effondrés tellement
elle ne savait rien ces fiches elle
était elle ne connaît rien à l'économie
j'espère qu'elle a travaillé depuis cinq
ans qu'elle a quand même des insultes à
la bouche et sur la légion et les nuls
on a vu les français n'ont vu en quoi
c'est des français l'ont fait les
français l'ont mise au second tour et
pour l'instant et
jusqu'à il ya quand même un point très
important c'est que dès qu'il ya une
femme au second tour c'est le cas
aujourd'hui que mal de peine c'était
déjà le cas avec ségolène royal est à ce
procès en incompétence qui était moins
sexiste est ce que on peut pas attaquer
systématiquement la forêt
on forme